youtuber house tour hell yeah
tearless it makes sense to do tearless
out of this i will rate
youtubers houses because i have the
authority
and saltiness you know i'm literally
living in my office right now
been doing that for the past year and a
half
because we're waiting to move to japan
let's start off with the ace family
house tour
gotta have some sort of montage of their
success in the beginning
which we are going to skip over okay
here's the house
yo they got balls i like that
more balls okay i'm into it
i assume they live in l.a that looks
[ __ ] massive dude
bro 20 million subscribers how many
views 4 billion
like me steinway please play something
that welcomes the ace family to the
house
they have an ai piano that's kind of
sick
all right
[Music]
let me introduce you to beyonce i
actually like that's
funny oh more balls hell yeah
okay you're you're being too smug about
it now i hate it thank you
so basically we wanted a piano for the
house um
obviously we want ellen elaine to
eventually learn how to play piano i
actually want to learn how to play the
piano so we went in to go look at pianos
and we were like gonna walk out and then
this lady was like okay wait no
before you guys leave you guys have to
see this piano plays by itself
neither of them plays the piano this is
the most rich person thing
isn't it all right so let's first start
talking about this entryway so
they got balls everywhere are they
lights i've got these huge
balls i got a chain you got this
heavy chain that's probably 100 okay but
why
why is there a chain there oh it's art
it's our specific reason you got it no
it's just a chain
okay this couch right here is actually
interesting because we were
contemplating
on buying it for like six months because
the price was outrageous but
it just fit perfectly with this area
that we no it sticks out what do you
mean
it doesn't fit perfect at all it's a
nice couch though i will say that
i'm not a couch hater is that his merch
eat sleep aids
uh let me just break this down they
they didn't buy that couch because it
was so expensive
even for the ace family so they waited
six to seven months
but it's not a cat main couch it's just
a couch for the entrance
okay cool just had to get it baby
another thing too is like okay so
originally when we were when we
were um getting all the furniture for
the house we actually thought to put
this over there in that corner and then
put the piano in this corner when we
moved in this actually ended up being
too big to put it over there
and so you should have spent another six
to seven months
contemplating it so you would know the
couch would fit or not
piano over there and then come to find
out we actually couldn't keep it there
because there's no outlet
so we had to have the builder literally
reconstruct an outlet
cut the floor oh my god
oh my god this paints me i hate this all
right let's move on to their living room
probably the quickest room we put
together but it really ended up working
out exactly how we want it
okay it's nice i don't know what to tell
you i like the floor
it's a lot of white especially a white
sofa for a young family right
seems like a bad idea that reminds me
actually i used to have that
as someone that grew up with a white
sofa
i remember spilling on it one day and
then i was like what'd i do i'll just
turn the pillows over
and then when my parents had guests over
they were like all right let's turn the
pillars over now that we have guests
and they found lo and behold my little
secret
[Music]
so oh bryce
you got this giant couch like this when
we put together
ginormous can fit like what a hundred
people
so and you get that tv oh
dude just sell the couch that you have
in the way i know
austin you're watching check this out
get this
these are sick get this austin
get this get a nice tv austin look at
that how cool is that super thin
what not not this not this not this
another crazy piece
people keep saying like okay um overall
it's a lot of black it's a lot of white
it's a lot of balls
like stranger things i saw some plants
but i think
i like white it's clean and nice
surfaces but it makes it
it just kind of likes a little bit of
color i think if you have
some piece that is cool with some color
it could bring more life
into the whole room i'm speaking like
i'm an interior designer or some [ __ ]
i don't know i literally have the same
uh what is that
fireplace thing what the [ __ ] never seen
the show
i don't understand what we're talking
about but it is strange that's what
they're saying kind of reminds me of
like ursula
like little mermaid like something like
just i don't know it's very unique i
like it
okay over here this is where our family
is majority of the time so that's your
main living room and that's the tv you
have
i don't know i'm stuck on the tv thing i
can't get past sorry probably the most
comfortable couch
in the world i love them it is scary
that we have an
all-white couch i must say with two kids
one three-year-old and one time there
you go
yeah it's a bad idea okay probably spend
like
60 70 of my time cleaning the house um
majority of the time i'm just cleaning
the couch but another thing too is like
i'm i'm teaching the girls how to be
very cautious and clean and like
not put their dirty feet on the couch
and stuff so it ends up working out oh
wait
wait i gotta show them the fireplace
whenever you wanna
you can click on it i didn't know that
kitchen okay moving on i like the
waterfall
stone thing i think that's what it's
called when it goes all the way
nice i do like marble but not
particularly this kind of marble
i like the big fridge that looks nice
maybe he looks a bit out of character
that's my only complaint but it's a nice
kitchen don't get me wrong
does the fridge come out as a robot it
doesn't look like it
i'm judging this so harshly like i will
be stoked to have this house like
okay so they're on one of their 500
balconies
and then i also put they got a cinema
room here if you have a drink i can
light it up for you
um yes oh did they get the one with the
heated cups or cooled cups did someone
be sitting here nobody oh nobody nobody
okay cool
if nobody's sitting here then i can do
this for you because i am gonna bring
you food
okay oh really thank you and if you want
to you know some popcorn
popcorn yeah yes of course and uh if you
want to see what you're eating
so you don't eat your fingers and then i
also put in these massive teddy bears to
keep you happy oh my god guys so
remember how a couple
of videos ago i was saying that i was
trying to
i'm not jealous but i got a beat here
there you go
overall a bit generic and looks like
your typical rich people house
black's character i'm really missing
that
um you know to take them higher but it's
a nice house don't get me wrong
moving on david dobrik
literally every youtuber that's like
rich
have a wine room and i just doubt they
ever will use the wine room
it's just like these houses are built
sort of from some successful
40 year old you know older person
they're not built for like young social
media media influencers
i wonder what those that kind of house
would look like in mine
[Music]
okay so it looks very much like the aves
family's house i did see some
wood integrated so it makes it a little
bit more interesting i guess
i think overall you know david being a
sociopath and with lacking any
actual personality i think that also
shows in this house
like where is he in this do you think
like it looks good
don't get me wrong but this is his house
and there's no way to know that
i guess he just moved in oh okay yes
yeah okay here we go
okay this is definitely more more like
david's house because there's alcohol
everywhere
[Music]
that's it david dobrik house
it's also beat here no see there because
i don't like them
so next up we have emma chamberlain i
remember seeing this
let's jump and i actually really liked
it emma as well as the rest of her
friends and family we will not be
releasing the address or town is located
wow
we also increased that's so that's so
nice of you any home
to not release your editors wow thank
you i like the exterior it's cool
obviously a bit samey to the neighbors
probably the same small
land in the heart of los angeles having
any yard space at all is sure to be a
luxury the home was built in 2016. i
like the open space too over the garden
that's cool
with an original listing price of three
million nine hundred and eighty five
thousand dollars and then
we got some different colors working as
well here not just
all white it looks like she has a
fireplace as well and they went for an
actual nice one not
the one i have which is just a cheap
amazon home in march of 2012
uh we got integrated working here a
unique stylish kitchen
i like playing for a steal price of 3.9
i like this a lot
this home has already turned into a
smart investment for emma's the current
appraised value
and it's a good investment look at that
million 80 000
since emma owns the home and does not
lease the home she will be responsible
for the roughly 47 000
per year in property taxes what
47 000 oh
america was land of free what the [ __ ]
is this it's paying four
thousand about property tax
what the [ __ ] you can rent for that
money
i'm crying what the [ __ ] is this tax as
well i have tap tax
over roughly 16 000 per year in
homeowners insurance
so after the 3.9 million dollar price
tag emma will be responsible for roughly
63
000 per year in basic home ownership you
made it
you successfully made it you did the
impossible what everyone strives to do
also you got to pay us 63 000 a year all
right
sounds like a coffee and that doesn't
even include utilities the home is a
four bedroom five bathroom with four
thousand
seventy-five square feet of living space
break i love the bathroom but
yeah about well it's cool fifty seven
dollars per square foot diving into the
door fireplace is amazing with a
beautiful open floor plan
oh my god it's gorgeous the entrance way
is our first bedroom with an ensuite
bathroom that doubles as an office space
moving back past the staircase to the
second floor you pass through i don't
like this dining room to the right
that's cool with the outdoor though i
like this house
to the one car garage stepping deeper
into the home you enter into the main
living area outfitted with a massive gas
fireplace
oh big minus on the tv but it doesn't
look good there is that axe is the focal
point for the room the wall to the
backyard is lined with pocket sliding
glass doors that when you open create a
seamless indoor outdoor experience yeah
stepping into the tailgate
there is a decent sized swimming pool
that is built in a way where the water
level is flush with the grass you walk
on
it almost creates this edgeless effect
which makes it feel super luxurious
the backyard also comes with an awesome
cup okay emma's
definitely best so far apparently she's
moving out
so she's not even keeping this property
i i mean that's
i don't i mean that's close to s2
i like it okay moving on to
sniper wall what do you want ups man do
you have a package for me okay come on
in
welcome to my house
is that a joke i don't understand what
just happened okay we got it blasted
with white again jesus christ
[Applause]
okay so these are right here i just
bought these and i want to show it to
you doesn't it look like
a luscious well taken care of plants
well it's not it's an
artificial sphere it's a ball rich
people and balls what's the matter with
this
over here and ash was always just like
jumping on them and
by oh my god i don't care show us the
place my god
see guys the doors open both ways yes
and there are glass doors which is
absolutely
horrible for audio quality yeah i was
just thinking that what the [ __ ] a wall
of audio foam and oh by the way this is
my
setup where i record where all the magic
happens
terrible setup looks awful okay maybe
they just recently moved in but it looks
a bit barren
and not in a minimalistic sense just
like what
so i wanted this mirror for the longest
time i love this mirror and then
we finally got it and it doesn't really
go without
we also wanted a nice couch like what
that couch is too small you got to get
the massive couch like everyone and
there's a couch over here
too what's happening here what is that
he did me so
dirty i waited six months and look at it
this piece does not match these two
pieces and they still haven't resolved
my damage
i'm trying to figure out what's wrong
with this couch what the [ __ ] what is
happening
so please if you are watching this i
want a new couch and i want it now
because this is like unusable like you
can barely even sit on this like this is
horrible
so this is the rest of the house it's a
great they haven't put up a tv yet
and they don't have a carpet this looks
so
okay that's not messed up this is one of
the kind
it's basically made of what your bed is
made of so it's like a giant
bed what's with all the drains is that
electrical sockets
okay kitchen's knives no handles
which i like except on the fridge it
looks like usually i feel like i've seen
a lot of these and the handles kind of
cheapens it of course they gotta have
the wine fridge
dude i just stored g fuel in there that
would be amazing where i keep everything
that doesn't have a permanent home and
it's just basically like things i get in
the mail
bills more bills and a lot of cleaners
because i like to keep this house like
as clean as i possibly can so i'm like
always cleaning but yeah this is the
kitchen my favorite part of the house
and we have a
super stupid long island this island is
ginormous and it's great because i can
like i cook on it you guys have seen my
like cooking videos here on my second
channel i've been doing a lot of cooking
big sink respect that how do you think
this opens so
you just you press it and then it opens
up like that and then to close it you
just like put it back wow
but why
yeah i like that looks clean so over
here is the secret door
except then you ruined it by adding
handles here what the [ __ ]
we thought about this come on so this is
my favorite part of the house come on
in the second kitchen tea bar so this is
my little
face where all the tea making happens i
have a bunch of plants here i planted
everything so i have like all these
little cactuses
to remind me of arizona you're trying to
have a drink you always have
oh i want that ice machine please
literally what the [ __ ] is that bathroom
i don't like it no i like it okay so
here we also have like a really big
indoor outdoor space but you don't feel
it
the same way as in emma's house for
example like they're integrated with
each other
it just feels like you're actually going
outside and the door is massively a jar
right cool so here is the spa and it's
an infinity pool it looks cooler from
here because you can't see the edge
my foot itches i probably rate this
pretty similar if not lower
this is the low one so far yeah it
probably is
yeah i'll put it in seats here that
seems fair okay so i asked you guys
uh whose house tour you want me to see
and and people are like okay well if
you're not making a joke
check out bret man because it's actually
really nice
so this is an architectural digest video
so it should be nice
the problem is i've already seen this
video because i
i like watching people's house tours
and i i don't know i didn't really like
it too much
but i guess that's the thing it's all
about personal taste at least it has
character unlike most of the youtube
houses we saw it seen
and holy [ __ ] the view is amazing so he
lives in hawaii
this is my formal it looks unreal i feel
like it represents
a lot of like bretman rock it looks
it looks scattered i hate the fireplace
why would you have a fireplace in hawaii
why is this chair facing that way why
would you ever sit on this sofa
this is my live terrarium out here
i feel like it's just like a piece of
nature in my house
i like the idea of a live terrarium but
it just looks kind of
if he's watching he's gonna get mad but
it looks kind of tanky okay
moving on i also love the fireplace i
feel like fireplaces are really kind of
rare to see in hawaii because i wonder
why
does it get cold we don't have
fireplaces here and my favorite
i mean they're cozy chair out of like my
whole entire house
is this bloom chair from kenneth he is a
filipino designer
and it's called a blooming chick no
this is kind of like a mess
but like a hot mess so it's very much
like me it looks like a
security control room and he literally
has
security cameras right there uh yeah i
don't like it when i am working
sorry i like to surround myself with
what i'm working on and so that's why i
have all of my crocs in here
i also do a bunch what's the story
behind the crocs again
it looks uncomfortable like where are
you gonna rest your hands
if you're gaming on this setup right
also
an apple computer and gaming what is
happening here oh
oh that kitchen's bad oh
this looks like granny's kitchen what
the [ __ ]
family is over this is really where we
hang especially
my mom this is her space she's oh now i
feel bad he made it for his mom
okay the countertop and and then this
and that
oh the micro oh i would be lying to you
if i say i actually eat my breakfast
over here but it's just
oh it's kind of cute that's kind of cool
that works such a nice thing
to look at i love and he doesn't use
[Laughter]
love it over here it is my living room
living room not my formal living room
but my living room living room
so when people ask me what i do i often
just
show them this i'm a singer songwriter
actor
okay minus 100 you didn't hide the cable
so it looks terrible
oh so this is his recording space he's
got the markipliers
2018 setup dude look at that background
that looks
incredible around the world but i just
feel like hawaii mountains
just hit different it's just a magical
state
another fireplace that i never really
used because hawaii is so hot but
oh okay such a flex like it's also
really ugly i'm sorry
what is this this stone with this wood
and that fire
what right man gets a plus because
you know his character shows in the
house and you can tell he actually lives
in it
but i kind of really don't like it sorry
ah
okay i'll be generous i don't think i've
ever done a house tour
this is the closest a vlog oh god that
looks terrible
look at this i actually that setup is
more comfortable than
what i have here sometimes
can't really see much i didn't want to
show the house oh this is also early it
looks much better now
so yeah i haven't even put up the tv
anyway that was youtuber house tours
did you agree with my rankings or rate
thing
let me know if you want me to do another
one i think i would love to continue
this tier list because it's a bit
barren and there's a lot more house
tours but this video has gone long
enough so thank you for watching
like subscribe and i'll see you next
time
why did i just hit